i'm gonna i'm gonna text kaley and tell
kaley to tell mike d'antoni to get off
to a better start that was my first key
and the rockets certainly are not doing
that rivers with the pull
back not the fact the rockets are being
outscored by
14 of the paint but the technology is
amazing the interaction for fans and
jeffrey's just cut right in front of
covington
covington not uh following the
fundamentals of defense
rivers has been terrific off the bench
he's got 10. right here they get the
same thing with austin rivers so will
the
kings adjust and maybe run a player at
austin river plenty of times still eight
on the shot clock
rivers turns the corner steps back
ducks in scoop scores tied at 50. or
five matchup the season would end at
this very moment
rockets can still climb as high as two
and austin rivers climb the ladder there
for the monster two-handed slam to go
out there and start teeing them up
hard with the deflection rivers of the
open floor
and scores one on two those are the two
guys who have gotten the job done
all night long collins who can match up
with the big men
as you see austin rivers shaking and
bacon and nice
spin oh at the three
step back looking for 30. there it is
versatility
his switch ability was knocking down
threes to not
have him particularly in that series
against golden state
having a terrific game just brilliant
step back james harden brought the step
back three to the nba and now there's a
bunch of guys that are
emulating what james is doing 70 seconds
to go
rivers one on three and there it is
a new career high for austin rivers
good crossover picks it up definitely
that was the that was the previous one
yeah that was the one that got him at
39.